we've spent last year a hundred and
thirteen billion dollars on illegal
immigrants we have to do something about
it
and we have to start by building a wall
this is a Republican Party as most
people know it today the champ is drill
baby drill and that's what we hear all
across this country in our rallies
because people are so hungry for those
domestic sources of energy to be tapped
into my budget includes the largest
increase in defense spending in two
decades because while the price of
freedom and security is high it is never
too high but the GOP hasn't always been
anti-immigrant pro-war and fuel hungry
the time has come for men to make his
peace with nature every man woman and
child with a disability can now pass
through once closed doors into a bright
new era of equality independence and
freedom as far back as 1953 America was
home to a much more progressive
Republican Party every gun that is made
every warship launch every rocket fire
signifies in the final tenth a set from
Lowe's jr. and are not fit those who are
cold and are not close and 60 years ago
the party's presidential platform wanted
to raise the minimum wage expand Social
Security benefits and extend the 1953
refugee Relief Act
so when did the party takes such an
aggressive turn well the answer may lie
in a letter President Dwight Eisenhower
wrote to his brother in 1954 should any
political party attempt to abolish
Social Security unemployment insurance
and eliminate labor laws and farm
programs you would not hear of that
party again in our political history
there is a tiny slender group of course
that believes you can do these things
among them are a few Texas oil
millionaires and an occasional
politician or businessman from other
areas their number is negligible and
they are stupid but over the next few
decades that tiny group group
corporations became fast friends with a
religious right and that partnership
gave conservatives the money they so
desperately needed to call for an end to
big government then the costs of
campaigns began to balloon and that put
even more power in hands of the wealthy
so with billionaires now calling the
shots in US politics will the GOP ever
get back to its progressive roots